how do we move past our stories this
this one comes from Derek Macmillan hi
rich in your podcast with James all
teacher you both touched on how we move
past our stories rather than continuing
to be identified with who we were
whether it be an addict criminal etc how
do you develop a positive relationship
with your past without identifying with
it in the present and letting it dictate
who you will be in the future thanks
that's like the ultimate question that's
right that's yeah we all have these
stories that we tell ourselves about who
we are you know mine can be I'm an
alcoholic
or I'm an athlete yours could be I'm a
journalist so those are the labels that
we put you know there's professional
labels but there's also these more at
times and sidious stories that we
quietly privately tell ourselves about
who we are and what we're capable of I
can do I could yeah I could never do
that you know yeah like yeah like well
Goggins can do that but I can't do that
right he's like that and I'm like this
right right that's right I do it as much
as anybody I've done it historically
over my whole life and I think it's
important to understand that these
stories are illusion we fabricate them
it's like our brains want to make sense
of ourselves in our world and our past
and our capabilities it's like this
mapping device right and it's trying to
identify patterns there was a spiritual
teacher that I had many years ago and he
described it like buds on a branch like
if you take a tree branch and you see
the little buds where eventually
there'll be new branches right and we if
you look at that branch like a timeline
of your life we have a tendency as human
beings to identify these certain buds of
things that have happened in our past
and we weave them together to construct
a narrative mmm right so it might be my
father abused me or you know I wasn't
able to get into college or you know
whatever it is right like there are
certain instances like events that occur
and we hone in on those and we create
meaning around them
and then we weave them together but in
truth our life is made up of billions of
decisions and events that have occurred
over the course of our lifetime and
we're myopic to almost all of it except
for these little butts along the branch
right and we make this decision based on
illusion that these things are more
meaningful than everything else that's
happened to us and we construct an
identity around that and I think the
process of learning from that but not
identifying with it is one of
self-inquiry I think it's a lifetime
journey of deconstructing that and it
begins with mindfulness because the more
that you can be present in your life the
less you are the less you're shackled to
that past and that past as a predictor
of future behavior right so the most
tangible tactical advice I can give to
someone who's struggling with this is to
begin meditating and to try to learn how
to be more present in your life
I think these stories are important to
the extent that they can inform a better
path forward but detrimental to the
extent that we rely on them as limiters
and predictors of future behavior your
past doesn't dictate your future but it
will if you allow it to and I think in
most people's case that's what happens
you just say well because I'm this way
and this thing happened to me that I can
only do these things or I'm not capable
of doing these other things and freedom
comes with being in the present and
unshackling from that narrative
deconstructing it like really the
meaning well the more your present the
more your the more your wreath at less
reactive you are and the less prone you
are to just repeating some cycle you
know that some deep groove that's like
in your brain about how you behave
because you're open to what's coming at
you verses ready to defend against
what's coming at you you can you can
evaluate your circumstances more
objectively rather than reacting
impulsively to them
based upon some prior prat like when
this happens I always do this right I'm
not even thinking I just do it this is
how I respond to these situations you
know and understanding it that's
actually a choice but in order to really
embrace the fact that you have options
you need to be present to create that
little buffer of time wherein you can
reflect a little bit more deeply on
what's happening so that the behavior
that you choose to then lean into is is
coming from a more reflective place as
as as opposed to a you know like an
innate response right and I think when
you if you if you do an inventory of
your life you know I would I would
suggest people start with what are those
buds on your branch like get out a
notebook and write down all of those
things that you think form your identity
those those important events in your
life that you think are formative and
then I would challenge you to then find
other instances in your life that that
call into question the veracity of
whatever truth is that you're hanging
your hat on and I would imagine that
most people can find like like you know
I'm not I'm not worthy of being hired
for this kind of job because I I've been
fired three times in a row well have you
ever had a job where you didn't get
fired like try to try to put truth to
that lie in some regard and understand
that you have the power to create a new
narrative what you decide to focus on
becomes your reality so if you can free
yourself from being overly focused on
those buds along that branch and those
instances that create this story you
have the power to create a new story for
yourself what you decide to focus on
becomes your reality mm-hmm I mean
that's the that's the headline right
there right like our emotions sometimes
we feel like you know there's there's
right now especially there's this idea I
mean I don't even mean in in the context
of the political situation right now I
just mean in this generation and and
with so many people in therapy or
whatever you hear people saying well you
know everyone wants to express their
feelings and their feelings become
almost sacred but
every emotion needs to be right needs to
be validated right and not every emotion
is valid um it's it's you decide what
emotions are valid right and that's not
to say that if you've suffered a certain
trauma that you should pretend it didn't
happen to you you know if that's the
case that needs to be looked at like
seek out therapy like unpack that what's
behind that how is it holding you back
and and you know start to develop tools
to work through that so that it no
longer carries that charge in that power
that is inhibiting you what would be an
example of that for you that where you
had to move past a certain story in your
life maybe
I mean sobriety could be one but maybe
endurance sports what was it for you
that kind of like an example where you
constantly moved in a different
direction because you change story I
think I can give you two I mean one is
where I'm still kind of very much in a
story and one is where I'm actively
moving past a story and the first is is
you know addiction and alcoholism is
tricky right because I am an alcoholic
and I think there's certain people who
will tell you that they are they've
cured themselves of alcoholism or
they've transcended it and it's not for
me to judge that person's experience
maybe they have and if they have that's
fantastic but I I know that I have
alcoholism and that I need to treat it
and that treatment involves 12-step and
working with other alcoholics etc I have
a whole 12-step program for dealing with
this I will never like be cured of
alcoholism but that doesn't mean that
that that the fact that I'm an alcoholic
needs to define my entire life
experience it's something that I have
that I have to deal with and my first
priority as an alcoholic is to is to
help other alcoholics achieve sobriety
like I'm very unclear on that but that
doesn't mean that I'm like this single
issue person right you know I mean like
I do know people that are sober and that
are sober alcoholics and and basically
their entire life is about you know
talking about the fact that they have
alcoholism like
alcoholism is is something that almost
killed me and there's a whole story
behind that that I still hold on to I
don't allow it to identify Who I am but
it's a very powerful story in the sense
that it is a reminder that I as much as
I want to deny or ignore it that I have
a disease that would very much like me
dead hmm and then I have to remain
persistent in my recovery to abet that
internal urge inside of me that's doing
push-ups the minute I stop treating it
staying ahead of it right so that is a
story that that has truth to it
I don't overly identify with it but I
need to maintain the pertinence of that
story in my life in order to be well and
that's why when you go to like an a
meeting people get up to the podium and
they share what it was like what
happened and what it's like now and the
reason that they share what it was like
is a reminder to themselves as they're
sharing it and to everyone else like
this is where I came from like this is
why I do all these things now because I
would very much like to just forget that
I did all of those things and pretend it
didn't happen
yeah and it's important that I'm
reminded that that is you know
fundamentally who I was and who I could
return to being if I'm not vigilant so
that would be that one example of where
I maintain a connection to this story
for a healthy reason yep another example
would be this pivot that we're making
with the podcast right now it would be
very easy for me to just say well I'm an
I'm this endurance athlete and I'm a
vegan and I do a podcast about those
issues we're going to talk about
nutrition and how to be like an Ironman
triathlete or whatever and like stay in
your lane rich trust me I'm on the
receiving end of a lot of stay in your
lane comments these days which is weird
because your lane has always been pretty
wide there's a lot of people who would
very much like me to go back to that
Lane and stay there anyone triathlete
putt that's a story that's powerful like
I could just stay in this place of like
oh I did five Iron Man's on five
Hawaiian Islands and tell that story
again and again and again and allow that
to kind
dictate how I communicate publicly yeah
I'm not that interested in that that was
a while ago like I'm in a different
place right now where you know I've
grown I still am an endurance athlete
and I love all that stuff but it's
important to evolve right and we're
trying to evolve the podcast a little
bit right now by doing what we're doing
right now and I don't want to allow that
story of who I was to dictate what I
have to be in the future that story is
powerful and I can leverage it as a way
of reminding me that I'm capable of
putting anything I put my mind to yeah
because I've done some hard things I
know that I'm capable of more than that
other old story tells me which is that
you know you know I'm not good and I'm
an imposter syndrome I know there's
another question about that that we can
get into yeah so I use those stories for
the benefit that they can give me but I
don't try to I don't allow them to
hinder me from growth if that makes
sense yeah I think that answers this
question it totally makes sense I think
it does I'm you know the the idea that
we should be focused on not what we did
but where we're going not where we've
been but where we're going but the
reason I think people love that story
also is because you know the story of
your rich role the endurance athlete is
because as so many of your listeners
they they would like to get to the point
where they have kind of some sort of
physical mastery or getting better and
because it's interesting would you be at
the place you are now if you hadn't gone
through the crucible of ultra which
allow them to see yourself like we
talked to you talk about meditation I
don't know if you meditate daily or not
but comparing that to what you learn
about yourself in an ultra it's it must
be those are kind of they're not just
buds on the branch they're kind of their
formative experience yeah they're like
what do you like I'm spacing on the word
in India like a yoga like where people
come an ashram they're kind of like the
ashram of the mind in a way
yeah I mean I've always and I'm happy to
talk about all those things because I
want everybody to have their version of
that experience that I had for myself
because it was so formative so endurance
sports will always remain you know a
heart place on this show like I love
talking to endurance athletes and
exploring the teachings of that pursuit
right but I would also say that I got
into an endurance sports to learn more
about myself not to just become an
endurance athlete
it wasn't about podiums and winning
races and all of that and also wasn't
about you know being a competitive
athlete for the rest of my life like I
wanted to more deeply connect with who I
Who I am so that I could be more
authentic in my expression of myself and
as a result of having that experience I
learned a lot about myself and I'm
committed to continually growing and
evolving rather than just doing this one
thing staying in my lane and you know
pleasing a certain number of people and
because what's the point if you're not
going to continue to get outside of your
comfort zone and challenge yourself and
grow and the point of pushing the
comfort zone is is to remind yourself or
learn the lesson over and over again
that I can I can be more than I thought
I was right and I can do I can I there's
there's more to me and that empowers the
ability to transcend those stories that
hold you back actually so it's like a
feedback right it's not yeah it's a
positive feedback it's a positive
feedback and and that plays into I don't
know you know Angela Davis legendary
Black Panther and an activist for you
know decades I saw a quote from her this
week and it was something like I I
constantly I can be an activist because
I'm always because I'm positive we are
going to get there I'm positive it's
going to change there is an optimism and
optimism to it knowing that it will
happen mm-hmm and and I think that
there's a parallel here as well moving
past the story you can move past the
story when you know there's
place to go right and that begins just
to cap it off and we'll move on to the
next story like that begins with
mindfulness practices but it also I
would say a close cousin to that is
commit yourself to doing something that
that contravenes whatever that story is
even if it's a tiny small twin mm you
know create that little goal that would
put into question the veracity of
whatever story you're telling yourself
and with that small win you can then
build on it and ultimately you know
crater the sandcastle of that imaginary
story that you've been telling yourself
your whole life that's holding you back
I love that
[Music]